[Música]
llegó el momento hablar de salud con más
romeros a la mar muy buen día la salud
en nuestro estudio de directo américa
empecemos entonces con las últimas
investigaciones del cobi 19 le preguntó
qué novedades hay sobre el hobbit largo
y las personas contagiadas de esta
enfermedad y que es un poco el cómic
largo cierto exacto pues no son noticias
especialmente alentadoras es un estudio
de la universidad de oxford que estudió
a más de 270 mil personas que han sido
diagnosticadas con kobe y lo que
encontraron es que el 37 por ciento de
estas personas todavía tenían síntomas
relacionados con la enfermedad hasta
tres o seis meses después de eso se
trata el kobe largo mantener estos
síntomas el síntoma con mayor
prevalencia que hubo fue el de ansiedad
y depresión un 15 por ciento de los
pacientes que habían tenido kobe todavía
reportaban tener estos efectos después
en meses después de haber sido afectados
también hablamos de problemas de
respiración dolor abdominal dolor de
pecho o fatiga aunque esto sobre todo
afectó a las personas más mayores la
mayoría de personas igualmente tuvo más
de un síntoma simultáneo es decir que
estar enfermos de varias cosas meses
después y tenían las dolencias más
intensas si habían sido hospitalizados
es importante raúl seguir la pista de
este tipo de investigaciones porque
recordemos que es un virus relativamente
nuevo y todavía no sabemos sus efectos a
largo plazo así es marc vamos a
concentrarnos ahora en nuestra región
porque las campañas de vacunación en
contra este eco y 19 avanzan de manera
muy desigual en el continente americano
este fue el primer el principal mensaje
de la organización panamericana de la
salud escuchemos lo que dijo su
directora en la rueda de prensa de ayer
es más yo ni la cobertura no es uniforme
mientras canadá chile uruguay y puerto
rico han vacunado completamente a más
del 70% de la población 10 países y
territorios de nuestra región todavía
tienen que alcanzar el 20 por ciento de
su población y en haití menos de un 1%
ha sido inmunizado hasta la fecha
hablando de haití particularmente un
momento porque ya que lo menciona y sólo
ha recibido 500.000 dosis de donaciones
desde eeuu pero teniendo en cuenta este
1% del que hablan quiere decir que
probablemente ni siquiera se han usado
todas las vacunas que han recibido y
precisamente para solucionar este tipo
de problemas en haití y en otros países
de la región la organización
panamericana de la salud anunció un
convenio para comprar 8 millones y medio
de vacunas así novak para poder
distribuirlas en toda la región además
también anunció unos convenios con
instituciones chilenas y brasileños para
que también se puedan producir estas
vacunas insumos médicos en la región y
no tener que importarlos todos
recordemos aún que sólo un 35 por ciento
de la población en el continente
americano está vacuna una cifra lejos de
lo ideal mari cómo está su corazón pues
bien contento y estoy muy contento de
estar todas las mañanas acompañándolos
aquí en directo américa y por supuesto
contigo marc por supuesto que sí
hablemos de nuestro órgano porque ayer
fue el día internacional de las
enfermedades que afectan este corazón
tan imprescindible para nuestro cuerpo
que tenemos que saber sobre esto más
pues empecemos hablando de enfermedades
y las enfermedades cardiovasculares son
todos esos que afectan al corazón a los
vasos sanguíneos y a la sangre
precisamente por ese día que
mencionábamos el director de la ms
emitió unas recomendaciones escuchamos
lo
las enfermedades cardiovasculares se
llevan demasiadas vidas gobiernos
sociedades e individuos todos juegan un
papel para combatir estas asesinas
silenciosas en el día mundial del
corazón elijan proteger su corazón con
un estilo de vida saludable y acudiendo
a revisiones médicas regular es
importante recordar que las enfermedades
cardiovasculares son las que más muertes
provocan en todo el mundo estamos
hablando de 18 millones de decesos
provocados por este tipo de enfermedades
la mayoría se tratan de ataques de
corazón también de derrames cerebrales y
súper importante decir que tres cuartas
partes ocurren en países con pocos
recursos o con ingresos medios además la
pandemia ha agravado toda la situación y
les evitan los chequeos médicos
regulares para empezar y además también
estas enfermedades son un factor de
riesgo a la hora de tener 19 pero
hablemos de las causas un momento hay
causas por supuesto personales no
factores como una buena dieta el consumo
de alcohol el consumo de tabaco pero es
importante que destaquemos los factores
estructurales hay enfermedades
cardiovasculares que son por ejemplo
predominantes entre las personas que
tienen peores condiciones laborales lo
decían hace apenas una semana también
hablamos de la contaminación atmosférica
donde vivimos también influye en que
enfermedades cardiovasculares
desarrollamos y por último también pues
por ejemplo comer bien también puede ser
una cuestión de clase no todo el mundo
tiene los recursos para mantener una
dieta balanceada una dieta equilibrada
entonces pues obviamente cuidarnos de
este tipo de enfermedades es algo
personal que también es una
responsabilidad nuestra pero también es
una responsabilidad colectiva así es
marc cuidar nuestro corazón a toda costa
porque sin él no podemos vivir ni sentir
muchísimas gracias por toda la
información mal vamos